foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
ghopal is basically the capital for
madhya pradesh madhya pradesh is the
central part of india
major we have middle class family and
many people migrating from villages
we have around
300 to 400 slum area slum pockets also
in 92 me and my husband anup we started
our organization arum in bhopal
we started working with small projects
even started picking up children near
the railway stations they were like
basically the rack pickers
so we started a small non-formal
education like you know center taking
out some money from our own pocket
we also run a number of projects which
have been funded by different funding
partners one of the project is the child
helpline
which is a government of india project
and it has got a special number 1098
which is a pan-india
number
and through childline we ensure that any
child who has been exploited or been
abused the child is protected
we have been working with children three
children and all kind of exploitation
which have been faced by children but
child marriage was never a focus area
for us because we hardly got any
call on this
earlier people were not reporting now
people are reporting
so now we come to know that child
marriage is happening at a prominent
level
just because of
nearby atmosphere lack of education
[Music]
and we start talking to them discussing
and then just making them aware that you
should not do this so if people agree
happily so in that case what we do is we
take the entire family to the police
station and then we have a document been
prepared in the police station and that
they will not get their children married
before the age
in some cases where you know the people
become very adamant you know they start
fighting then
there's a whole community surrounded
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
suddenly we had never realized that 1098
will be flooded with child marriage
cases
before covet 1718 we had around 27 cases
and 1920 we had covet we had around 35
or 34 cases
and then 2021 we suddenly it was like 54
cases so it just shooted up like that
there were lot many reasons
the government they are talking about
this you know the marriage age should be
increased from 18 to 21 for a girl
so now
most of the marriages are happening
because of that fear
there are number of girls you know four
or five girls in the family
maybe now we have more of families who
have lost the
head of the family
and the mother is saying i won't be able
to take care
they said we don't have to invite many
guests
in less expenses we can get the marriage
done
[Music]
child marriage in india is a is an issue
uh in context of
the progressive laws of india and the
social context of india as such with the
tradition of
indian society believing in early
marriages that heritage of
belief lingers on since centuries and
that's why after the indian constitution
came up
india introduced a lot of new and
progressive laws
which hit at the social norms and the
whole issue of law enforcement then
becomes a challenge the police
forces is very concerned about
creating an impact by the exemplar
effect of
enforcement of the law you get a
information and you suddenly go and raid
that place and you do it there is an
exemplary effect other people come to
know that yes this is wrong
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
for every five marriages prevented
i would say there would have been 15 or
20 marriages
not even taking place which would have
taken place had these
public education programs would not have
taken place with the help of the ngos
like
archana thais ngo and other similar ngos
a
foreign
i am born and bought up in bhopal and i
studied in a convent school
our sisters who used to teach her they
used to do a lot of social work you know
they used to take us along in the
communities where they did kind of you
know some help to the families and all
so that all motivated me and i become
gradually that you know helping people
became a part of my uh you know
responsibility
[Music]
gopal had faced the gas tragedy in the
year 1984 and that time i was a student
of social work
we got the opportunity to work with
these
affected families and also especially
with the children because many children
were left
alone their parents were dead and then
connecting them with their extended
family that was one of the major area
with what we did
[Music]
and many children were also orphaned so
we connected them with the
shelter homes we connected them with the
orphanages since then i wanted to work
for my city
[Music]
foreign
um
[Music]
what we have done is the right thing
because
it's not just about marriage it's about
you know what happens after marriage if
it is done before 18 years
there are health issues economical
issues
maybe today she is not understanding
tomorrow she will really understand that
what was done for her was right now she
is sad
so this sadness is like
making us feel little uncomfortable
because you know she is already
grown up and we are we will be not in a
position to put her in a regular school
so we feel bad
and we are not able to find out many
ways many opportunities for her to you
know do something in her life and do
something for herself definitely this is
a setback
these issues teach us a lot
when the child was being rescued from
the abusive situation and now when i see
the children doing good
and when the children
call me back and then they tell about
their success their own family
and
what they're doing and still they
remember me that's the most satisfying
thing which i get
[Music]
to stand up to fight in this
world of men
to
make my own position was a big challenge
for me
but i got a support from my husband he
said i don't want you to be recognized
as my wife
i'll feel proud when people will say
that i am your husband
[Music]
there were quite a few situations in all
these 30 years
where you know people tried to put me
down
because my father used to say it's your
fight you have to do it
so it was always my fight and i
am happy that i won
all the fights i have won
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you